[Music]
we've got flying kick worm face and gate
swans gay swans kicks wants those swans
that are like swans are pretty gay
though for real black swans are my
favorite why cuz they're all black and
they're beautiful
oh man I don't think I've seen a real
life like one I've never seen gay swans
but [ __ ] but like I think I've seen some
pretty gay birds what the hell is
happening right now I've never seen
swans [ __ ] in general I'm the only one
staying on topic well our first topic
though he's not even oh yeah it's stupid
it's about a flying mrs. Swan good yeah
I remember mrs. why was his first family
guy dude I was in dying and I I couldn't
breathe I was laughing so [ __ ] hard
and then when she came on again next
week I got that tape and I recorded that
[ __ ] part cuz I my brother and I just
could not stop even Asian no she's
Jewish
that's borstal she [ __ ] just killed
it so hard to give a [ __ ] you know
what's crazy
I didn't know she was pretending to be
Asian I just thought it was a weird
character like an old lady
maybe when I was a kid too I thought I
thought it was so funny yes surely I
didn't know and then you find out well
you're making for the beat yeah I didn't
know my friend's dad was like yeah
some people think Asian accents are
funny and I'm like it's so horribly done
what is she supposed to be Korean ajumma
yeah
she's supposed to be an old Asian late a
Korean a Jamaat that used to do her
nails so it's like it's the natural
person she's imitating okay okay because
when you look at her she looked exactly
like a Korean ahjumma it's actually
really accurate yeah her hair
yeah her hair the outfit the [ __ ]
yeah yeah yes but that's exactly what
created muslin I thought she was just a
senile old lady yeah yeah I didn't know
well anyway okay
so in downtown LA if it was the homeless
dude walking around with the 2x4 the
head of nails out of it oh my god okay
so I gotta say this so a lot of people
go hey you guys are all very empathetic
toward homeless people or whatever right
who says this is this is a perfect
example of what an LA homeless is like
in the [ __ ] that we deal with on a very
regular yeah look you guys would know
the best is you both live in downtown
yeah but look at this [ __ ] not only that
a little I just went through it
throughout my lifestyle throw my
lifetime that's it but I'm saying like
you're like now I'm living it yeah like
like this oh my god it's calm down but
this still happens alright so this story
like I said homeless man 2x4 with the
nail sticking out of it he just randomly
attacks this innocent man oh my gosh he
hits them in the face and they like cut
open his lips with the 2x4 dangling it
was dangling
oh my god this brave Good Samaritan out
of nowhere it comes out and does this he
gets his own to buy clothes does he like
we're about to see some karate some
board breaking right here that's a good
kick I love those kids it looked like
you were falling asleep in there though
[Laughter]
he tries to use it again Oh transient is
holding a piece of plywood with a metal
nail in it turns out he just boom attack
on an innocent man walking his dog till
he jumped me psychic damn yeah yeah he
didn't tuck his bottom leg though yes
Warren was a little long I wasn't clean
good for him he's a savior so this is
how the homeless dude with left what my
sidekick [ __ ] him up not just from the
kick he beat him up it's not just from
the kick oh no no he got up and started
swinging and running away and then like
they put him under citizen's arrest
yeah you saw the full video yeah yeah I
saw I saw this video he basically tried
to run away attacking other people and
then so like like the jump kicker yeah
he went and chased him and another guy
down and and when he tackled him the guy
fell face-first oh he wouldn't let go
his weapon so they like beat it out of
them so a lot of [ __ ] went down yeah so
he got arrested obviously yeah aliens
people are scary you know the other day
I was at the in South Pasadena so I I
always parked my car in the same parking
lot and in in South Pasadena even though
it's a very nice area if for some reason
that one area there's a lot of homeless
people on Colorado isn't it like a
clinic or a shelters on me I think
that's what it is and then so like that
was like following me around and I'm not
sure if he was gonna do something to me
but for sure that [ __ ] didn't
have a car in the parking lot but he was
I was at the the elevator and I was
going in he was kind of off this I'm
just kind of looking over like this and
that was like oh [ __ ] I think these guys
try to rob me you know to meet yeah so
he kept on going into the thing and then
literally he's trying to go the elbe I
was like nope he was like what I was
like you're not coming in now he's
[ __ ] closed the door on him cuz he
kept on lurking or any listen to you
yeah [ __ ] dude you know what I mean
yeah but you do look like an easy nope
I had a similar story in downtown - I
was late at night and this homeless dude
was walking up on me behind me as I came
out how much you got on you and I was
like oh [ __ ] anything he's like don't
[ __ ] with me man I got needles I [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] me I crochet don't [ __ ] me I
got AIDS on me it's like I got a gun is
like alright you got a gun all right
cool
but that's like I got needles
you wanna hear some sad [ __ ] though like
after I close the door I felt bad
because what if he was just a normal
person and then I felt kind of bad
friends out there and I was like I just
closed the door on this guy better safe
than sorry dude yeah because like that
levator not the [ __ ] access to his
bank account I know but still but what
if he was just a normal person but for
sure he wasn't though cuz he was like
legit follow me stop legit follow me
stop Fanny Price smelled like [ __ ] I
don't know about that part but it was a
little weird cuz I had my my gear bag on
me what if it was a fanny want to take a
picture man I know he's weird cuz I
don't usually have those like spiders
said his tinglies anymore like when I
was younger cuz he just grew up in a bad
neighborhood people just like jack
people all the time so it was like so
weird I felt like a little kid again I
was oh [ __ ] this guy's try to jack me
you know I mean it was kind of weird
yeah and then even the next day after
that there was a lady that was like
cuffed to the to those poles I guess
like in that parking lot area like damn
do is just weird out here I would never
want to fight a homeless guy only one I
know five people good hygiene if I fly
the homeless , spray to spray the
Cologne first I didn't spring
disinfectant
everything was spray spray everything
and you're not you're not fighting
someone of a sane mind like they could
bite they got AIDS
they could pee on you damn shower two of
those three things they could but I'm
not eight from writing them well that's
the only one they have up on you but you
can vomit in your mouth you could be
like I got away
even trigger that so bad I think you're
gonna start teaching me how to do like
people don't know they were talking
about regular Hoffman a hunter we are
talking about the drug addicts on Skid
Row that choose to be there and they
have superhuman strength yes they can
[ __ ] lift cars and throw that [ __ ] at
people dude I've seen it
that shit's no joke all right next story
this 32 year old woman from Russia
donut I can't see her she's probably hot
well we can't see her entire face
because she posted photos of a lump that
was moving around her face you can't do
it I'll throw up I will throw deposit or
a tumor nose worms
Oh a live worm
what kind of worm a parasitic worm [ __ ]
was moving around her she couldn't kill
it I would have [ __ ] it rub them no it
was she was just like what is this weird
lovely yeah it's my gravy wooden how did
she get it so she was out in like the
woods into the woods in Russia
wait what part of her body is Exhibit D
I think that's the worm this is the worm
I thought I was like that's my shoulder
oh my why you got a green shoulder I
didn't noticed the let your LASIK is
really good dude oh [ __ ] I'm right next
to like a berry till there's a letter
there
but what's Exhibit D exactly what part
of the body doesn't follow the pattern
all body parts all that must be her
shoulder or her butt sheet but it's
green for some reason it looks like a
[ __ ] little [ __ ] dude for like a
children's signature this specific type
of parasite it usually only lives in
like cats or dogs like animals she been
[ __ ] a cat no so is the way she got
it was through a mosquito oh it's always
those [ __ ] mosquitoes why do we why
don't we need a mosquito we don't why
what are they weather but when things
got global in parasite things got global
and mosquitoes started moving where did
they start I don't know but they never
existed in Hawaii that's what I heard
cuz obviously because one day I was like
how how did the natives here deal with
these mosquitoes and [ __ ] and I looked
it up and they're like actually there
was no mosquitoes until people brought
them on ships and I was like oh that's
uh it seems like Hawaii would be the
perfect place for mosquitoes is all hot
and wet and humid I heard that uh Bill
Gates is China like he's spent a lot of
money to try to get mosquitoes to kill
each other during sex but I don't know
awesome that's very nice of Bill Gates
don't they even spread the disease in
Africa like a West Nile area I bolas
mm-hmm I believe Alice's [ __ ] what
about the ones where that's why people
from West Africa have sickle cell
because it's like to kill the [ __ ]
most Guido's you heard about that one
moving on to their last story huh the
gays one no we were talking about you
know you you have case one is it two
guys or two girls so there were Paris
wands in Austria that sounds like a very
offensive term you pair swans that's
where we saw swans - yeah so there are
two male swans
oh they're really gay I thought they
were just fabulous wands no they weren't
they're actually apparently like booty
buddies together and they were
protecting they were protecting this
right to love each other this plastic
red cup which to them it was like their
adopted egg and so they were protecting
it anytime anyone swam they would attack
them so they had someone forcibly remove
a little party cup huh
this is one of them what are you
holy moly yeah that thing is big
have you seen when they get food and
they eat their [ __ ] cute so they put
their whole head in the water and then
just there but like they take little
Donald Duck oh it's just floating it's
so [ __ ] cute dude man that old lady
got big-ass boobs I think they've been
that big I usually don't get bigger the
older you get
damn man I'd like to see your younger
Pig really you don't think so no they
sag they're older lady if you gain
weight they get bigger but so maybe she
got fatter possibly but I mean she's
they you don't get like significantly
bigger like if you're a small busted
you're gonna stay small it's just
there's just no other fat that gets like
pushed in there um but they do get sag
here so she's probably always had
today's they look inconvenient don't
they they are pretty inconvenient at
that size they look kind of Mexican
though what does that mean the titties
do no the couple that looks like a park
in California and two mexican couple
just holding a big bird they don't look
Mexican the guy looks a little Mexican
not really white people yeah they look
like - I didn't it - that's true all
from here yeah yeah when I look at her
now yeah she does that big boobs when
she brought that yeah [ __ ] huge man
she got she's motherly to swans on there
dude I never seen this is actually not a
picture of this one the two swans are
right here
that's a stuffed animal yeah leave her
titties alone we're not big you fight
about we're just saying like what did
nothing you are just saying leave them
alone I absolutely won't where's the
boyfriend I don't know they separated
the two I'm telling you also look up the
Black Swans they're [ __ ] beautiful
I'm not a big fan of birds and then they
look beautiful white birds um they just
annoying I like baby birds make us so
much annoying my favorite sound in the
morning to wake up to all the harpies
chirping birds really yeah in the
morning not at night good morning it's
so it's like it's just it's the most
picturesque Wow those things look evil
as [ __ ] the Black Swan yeah they look
evil no it's literally a white swan for
just all black with the red beak yep if
the red beak is what makes oh because if
it was just black all the way it would
look normal but the red beak makes it
look evil so just look like a roasted
duck yeah it just looks a little charred
it looks like it went through a fire
survive damn I don't know how big's want
do people eat swans probably in China
yeah I've never had goose before me
neither and one of his teeth a duck
there's always goose at the park that
are overconfident [ __ ] yeah did like try
to [ __ ] did my character this is my
territory they try to come up and [ __ ] I
was like man off [ __ ] front kick you
in a beak
Thanks no but yeah so this couple here
these gates ones they were super
overprotective that they even when they
would attack some of the bathers there
they would they would attack the bay
yeah but get away from my [ __ ] party
cup or just from the water it seems like
cuz they would even have to go to the
hospital because it would have severe oh
yeah there to call bitten by a dog or
anything no what the football team hurt
so they don't have teeth but they have
like these ridges so you know the beat
have you ever felt a beak before yeah
yeah well it's really it's really hard I
only put the outside of the beat no but
if you're feeding you got chicken or
whatever and then they get food from
your hand
it hurts yeah it kind of hurts yeah no
but they have like so they don't have
teeth but they have like these like
ridges and that's what they use as teeth
wait what are you getting attacked by
ducks what's going on your life no we
had a duck
400k yeah we had a duck named Drake
before Drake and ya know like I don't
know why he bit me but yeah he bit me in
it walking hurt did you eat the duck no
I didn't eat it well New Mexicans eat
duck I don't know probably I don't know
you're asking the to my cleaners I don't
eat yeah I had duck taco not too long
also they eat doctor it was pretty good
it sounds like that big [ __ ] favorite
bird to eat
definitely duck is not [ __ ] right so
what happened to the drink oh my uncle
owned a ranch and they gave him the yeah
they said he lived on a farm happily
ever after drama like that's why I'm
telling you man these birds that hang
out like at parks and we're around
people that's good they get too
confident man they need to be put in
their [ __ ] place
they're like thugs but that is their
place yeah but then you get put in their
place in the social hierarchy of animals
we are at the top I'll [ __ ] kick the
[ __ ] out of you [ __ ] goose geese yeah
gooses goose is you [ __ ]
loosey-goosey geese [ __ ] [ __ ] at
least I only want to fight animals that
are below waistline way below maybe
baloney cat line have you guys ever seen
a picture of you know is that emus are
like the [ __ ] scary version of an
ostrich oh yeah and they'll literally
rip out your [ __ ] guts yeah like
don't take you down and make these huge
talents and they've known to disembowel
people they're like Raptors and ostrich
[ __ ] and had a baby this is a movement
I was like all animals are my friend
where do a mousse come from I think
they're in Australia or Savannah or some
serious like that that looks like a ball
of hair or something yeah never look
like a [ __ ] native hut on stilts with
a face yeah so some primitive survival
[ __ ] I know something right I don't know
I don't look at no animals in Venice
I know it's dogs I don't know I always
look at an animal's eyes I don't know
about you but I did hear about ostrich
ostriches that if you look into their
eyes like they see your your eyeballs is
like shiny little like marbles and they
want to eat it and they leave oh hi Pat
your eyeballs too bad
eyes on earth you ain't picking no Joe
beats you oh yeah that is that's what
our evolutionary advantage it was Oh for
the EMU and the ostrich yep damn I could
do a to look my eyes are gone you look
stupid though but doesn't matter I also
have Al's but you still can't see okay I
can actually see with my eyes closed
because they're not closed they're open
it's a mystery
[Music]